peace of Justice
cartoon may be over 4 000 miles from the
UK
for the Sudanese living here the
conflict is much closer to home
in a statement the Sudanese of Junior
doctors Association has said we are
aware of 71 Sudanese NHS doctors who are
currently trapped in Sudan because of
the ongoing conflict and we are
concerned for their safety and the
safety of their spouses and children
what we would like to see is all in a
test doctors who are now trapped there
with their families to be evacuated
as a form of a priority
while diplomats and their families have
been evacuated others haven't been so
fortunate
there are more than 20 000 Sudanese
people living here in the UK many of
them are calling on the government to do
more to stop the escalating violence in
the country and to help bring back any
British citizens from cartoon
wanting this war to stop now and I mean
now because if this war continued the
Sudan will be finished I've been
speaking to my younger brother who is a
Pediatrics
he's literally imprisoned in his
apartment but the government hasn't yet
given assurances that all British
citizens will be evacuated I would say
to British Nationals in the region
please register with us we have
circulated a link so we know who is
there where they are so if an
opportunity arises we can find a way of
helping them it's unclear how many
British Nationals are currently in Sudan
but many will be desperate to know when
they can escape the violence and finally
return home
Alice Porter Sky News